brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment hello welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every Tuesday
2 p.m. pacific right here at gamespot
comms headquarters in San Francisco
which has been overrun by filthy
disgusting game developer people look at
the mother just creeping right oh we got
a couple on our couch what's going on my
god Armand my good friend coffee stain
studios developers of are you not
wearing a goat simulator sure today's is
the westport independence Oh Oh
fantastic we'll talk to you but that in
a second and Mike Bithell another
European game developer I know I creator
of Thomas was alone and of course volume
which will be seeing later this year mmm
this is closely uh-oh you need to put
your mics on apparently I haven't enough
yes a guess professionals Mike song all
right here we go there's one you've got
one robe on well i will add sub thousand
posts don't worry about it chris waters
is back hello you not you're not covered
in swine flu anymore whatever was i live
i went to upstate New York in February
guess what happens there you get the flu
and it's terrible uh-uh but I'm great
now are you heading back east for pax
again as we know I'm not see their am I
are either you guys since you're in the
condominium go go go one day just one
day just to kind of duck in quickly we
go absolutely exactly you guys come over
for GDC all the time Chris you were
talking earlier about like the sort of
what is the impetus for people to come
to GDC because as far as like the folks
who come to gamespot are concerned it's
kind of like a light news show but
obviously while you're here like that's
surely not why these gentlemen are here
yeah I mean what we as press it's only
been in recent years that there's really
been a burgeoning sort of scene of demos
and people throwing off their games at
GDC in the past it's been sort of like
it it is for game developers we are not
game developers like we what we can get
out of it is only sort of tangential but
I'm curious to know like what you guys
get out of it I mean obviously now
showing your game is one of the impetus
for coming but like do you sort of line
up like things you want to hear about
people you want to hear talk like is
this a resource for you professionally
are you networking sort of
what's the whole are you just like
getting drunk and wanna party yeah its
primary drinking like what's what why do
you come to Jesus it's kind of a thing
where you know you we're supposed to be
a show-off go simulator on xbox and our
new game though publishing but uh you
know there's a lot of love drinking a
lot of partying yeah but you like
anything good yeah yeah yeah so
obviously you guys are shopping Reggie
games tram is there any like talks
you've been to it all there's only like
you look down through the leg list of
panels and go you know what actually I
need to see that because some of the
most interesting stuff I've seen at GDC
have been just panels of people that
I've just like I've had an error to
spare and I've got in yes I mean that's
how generally how I do I don't plan out
too much because frankly like my
schedule is just like packed with the
stuff I'm here to do like work wise like
it's kind of you know I I have to go do
this press thing or I have to go and
meet this person to talk about this
platform whatever but yet for me like
the nice biz I've got half an hour
that's exciting like run excitedly and
find the first thing I can um but yeah
they're cool I'd not the only talk I've
been to so far heart is what I was on oh
really and that was middling was it are
a leo I was okay I was a little rush my
slice didn't work okay so I got to spend
I got to spend my car for now basically
apologizing well apparent just comics
talk which is on two dead tomorrow I
think maybe tomorrow he's got like a two
half hour presentation and then today he
decided he wasn't actually gonna use
slides so it's just gonna be John I'm
like talking for two and a half hours
but of all the people to listen to for
two and half hours like oh yeah Mandy
they put them just before lunchtime so
they could run over because they reckon
he's not going to stay within a slot as
well have you seen any talks in previous
years that you're interested you yell
about is that on try think the ones
they're really inspiring but I'm
actually I'm drawing by how about you I
like there's there's so much cool talks
to go to but i have a problem like
sitting down for an hour right III
usually want one on my home i play game
and i watch something on TV and I
sometimes have a cell phone up to so I
can watch Twitter and I can ankus if I
can sit for like five or ten minutes but
then I'm like you know no too much I've
got to do something yeah so you guys are
both based in Europe you still based in
London like that's right you're based on
mainland
Sweeting yeah so you know you're kind of
remote in your own way like I'm sure
there's a Swedish devotion community
does obviously luck on London were right
from America yeah you've changed you
used to think that the UK was alright
they swear boundary Irish boy with my
own at the waterford games developer
community was never that hot and what's
it like then like is there an element of
this where you're like you're meeting up
with people whoíve you've talked a lot
like online or collaborators all massive
like that's the best part of it it's
just like yeah especially like you I
spend a bit of time on Twitter you know
I've got loads of mates or online
friends and yeah it's just nice to
actually be able to see them like two or
three times a year like we see each
other this game's content enough that's
enough for me yeah like this they're
like this there's people I see what that
but most of them is like yeah you get
through the week I'm sure they feel same
way about me and you're like yeah okay
you can go back to where you live and
I'll go back to where i live we'll see
each other again soon I don't mean that
um but you know it's it's lovely it's
cool seeing those those old friends and
those old faces and catching up and
playing each other's games and yeah and
it's a bar is it mostly social or do you
feel like you're sort of getting like
even if it's not like sitting down going
to talk and like learning about
something specific do you think you're
like gaining experience from what other
people are creating oh yeah well the I
think it break everyone comes together
and yep shares shares and i think i
think the stuff that's really useful is
the thing a lot of people say this is is
it's not so much always the talks but
it's the conversation you have outside
the pub at three o'clock in the morning
with the like you know with maybe a
developer who's a bit more experience
than you or someone who's released a
game on a platform you're thinking of
doing yeah like right these are the 5
things you need to make sure you do this
way and it's like that's the value like
that genuinely that 20-minute
conversation with someone far cleverer
than me was worth the flight oh yeah was
that set me up and I've already had like
three of those conversations in like two
days so I'm feeling very good about the
trip and you guys were both at the mix
last night just down the road at the
idea buildings and what was that like
you've been into a couple of at this
stage no no that was my first one yeah I
was cool does that indie scene like seem
different to you than what it is like
two or three years ago because I was
kind of there was a time I guess we're
like a lot of those games you kind of
had they looked small
they looked like oh this is being made
by a small team but there were so many
games last night there and also on the
game spot string we had yesterday and
that just didn't look like what you know
my silly non developer mind would say
indie games yeah I'd like definitely
like a couple of years ago we we didn't
have as much money as like high quality
indie games especially not with unity
and Unreal Engine you see a lot of
really really cool stuff just made by by
indie developers I think as well it's a
generational thing and like it's
computers so the generations are like
weekly but like the other thing I think
I think what you're seeing there event
like the mix and it was fun walking
around is you're seeing like the girl
working in her spare time like you know
two hours a week and of just making
something in her bedroom at come and
then next to them you're seeing you know
the person who brag aim three years ago
did really well may put all the money
into this thing hopefully it'll sell
otherwise they're in trouble kind of
thing and then and everyone in between
and that's if the indie as a term is
starting to stretch because so many
andys have actually had some kind of
financial success and the budget allows
them to bring in more collaborators and
you get you know bigger bigger projects
so it's I think that's exciting I feel
it almost feels like we're rebuilding a
new game industry is like a little
bubble is kind of expanding and it's
kind of taking in different people and
doing different things but it seems like
the other one is contracting sometimes
as well like Chris we think of some of
the Triple A games that we cover or you
know does a reason why they just say
triple-a now and then in D because that
whole middle section seems to be just
kind of like yeah be an entire sort of
middle road publishers that like make a
big game and you know have a sizable
budget but that has proven to be not
like the most financially viable yeah
past years and that's definitely changed
the scene it's and it's interesting to
hear talk about sort of the progression
of the indie development scene at GDC I
imagine you guys now you know if you're
you know a couple years ago you're sort
of looking to network but now are you
having people like seek you out as like
the guys who have shipped successful
games like a nice pretty in this tip or
that like I'm never going to get bored
of someone I don't know walking up to me
and asking me the fist bump with them
that's a never that's amazing like it
probably will last about six
all months our men will never happen
again by volume um but the but it's kind
of it's it's a it's a weird thing it's
eight but that cycle happens and it's
fun watching that I I don't I guess it's
hard to kind of tell when you're at the
epicenter of it but I love watching
happen to other people if I love like
when you'll when they'll be when you'll
like you'll know some guy that you had
breakfast with two years ago and they
were talking to you about their weird
idea and then you're right you you meet
the bit of em I listen it's like oh
you're now that you're now the guy who
made that game I take it over everyone's
obsessed with it's like I remember when
you know I bought you some pancakes
because left your wallet at home
everybody hope that's amazing I remember
when we'd a burger and the Lord Nelson
but under ya are from work chat about or
like those how long those Alexander when
we did like a Skype interview for that
video I made and yeah dudes like
antechamber gave me worked on for like
two decades ended up like being really
successful and I am it's great do you
think just you touch another point it's
the last point with this you touched on
something about the technology you're
using unity 5 right on volume i'm i'm
easy i am using 85 using a beta
beautiful okay so is that like do you
think like like the progression of stuff
like unity has really helped like it
like enable developers who might have
otherwise had the tools to do it to like
maybe a bigger and better games I think
I think the engines are great because
what the engines have done is they've
they've they've basically geographically
moved the talent to this is such an old
trailer but he's definitely not even as
a relator this is really unity 40 but
yes I think what's happened is the tower
is is all that all these amazing
programmers and engineers that make
games work I'd literally make the
engines they have all gone to these big
companies like UNC like unreal and their
genius is then being distributed in a
way that allows all of us idiots to make
stuff and yeah just jumping almost
hurdles like I've worked in Games now
for about eight years and I remember the
10 the example I always use is my first
job for like six months was making nav
measures now I've mentioned it's boring
but it's basically it's the way we're
worse it's basic so i think i would say
basically it's it when an enemy runs
around a level it's the data that tells
that enemy where they
i'm home go right um and that was my
first job nice to be I was quite fast I
could do a room in a day and it took
like you know it's very laborious job
that's now in unity that's a thinker
naught point 27 millisecond process like
a compressor button it just does my
first job to those right okay with if
you're in the game sanctum I was like
the competence resting before the game
would go in it those is a lot like my
first I had a summer job and I was
supposed to like do the navmesh it's
like you Morrible it's kind of like you
know picking weeds when you're four it's
like I'm step down from basic rights
yeah like it's like this is like the
manual labor of the gaming industry
which now doesn't exist and today like
analyzing for just press the button yeah
like Janice but that's also like you
know you're like we actually do it and
we do it in volume we do it in at
runtime so when you're editing levels in
the game you press a button and it just
may automatically makes a nav mesh and
it's like oh my goodness but oh you know
I'm quite glad you're happy led to the
new ones but it's so exciting and it's
such a great opportunity for people
people met starting to make games now I
imagine I'm sure that when I started
eight years ago there were people who
started 16 years ago yes oh my god that
guy doesn't know he's born okay how
quickly can make enough miss you know I
said type those numbers in my hand and
so what's the new nav mesh what's the I
mean but just robots are taking all the
young developer jobs now I think I think
the next one I'd love to see someone a
unity really tackle the ins you're
unreal is ai ai is the thing that I
think is a stumbling but there's a
reason that a lot of indie games either
or you know a character moving around
the space with no enemies or kind of a
or enemies you know they're very kind of
straightforward logically and it's
because AI is really hard getting and
gang a either that's fun is hard you're
making an AI that sufficient is actually
very easy um it's making it inefficient
in a way it's entertaining right arm so
i think i think that's that's a
challenge i'd love to see me and you can
take on because i think if you can come
up with some kind of centralized and
there's a few things that they're
playing with but kind of some kind of
centralized AI solution that's going to
lead to such a big job can we can do
excellently for me it would be like if
you have a bot that would just
all the people to ask you when the xbox
for it is coming out one that was like
why is it crashing like some ball that
tells people just like shut up you're
talking you're talking but all I hear is
wah wah bike a successful right it's not
to feel sorry for you to be obvious
people you guys solve the AI problem go
to live I just not forget people to just
follow when you hit them yeah